pandémie aux anciens combattants tombés
au combat et leurs familles ainsi qu'à
tous ceux qui en sont venus et aux
militaires qui servent encore
aujourd'hui
alors il fait généralement un froid
glacial le 11 mai le 11 novembre mais
pas cette fois ci le temps est beaucoup
plus doux un peu gris comme c'est
souvent le cas le 11 novembre et tout de
suite on va aller rejoindre mon camarade
daniel thibault qui se trouvent place de
la confédération qui sera avec nous tout
au long de l'émission bonjour daniel
bonjour c'est daniel il ya généralement
des dizaines de milliers de personnes
qui se déplacent qui se pressent pour
cette cérémonie à tel point des fois
qu'on ferme le centre-ville d'ottawa
mais c'est vraiment pas le cas
aujourd'hui on a demandé aux gens de
rester chez eux
oui mais voilà alors le centre-ville il
il est fermé mais il est fermé pour
d'autres raisons aujourd'hui on a
demandé aux gens de suivre la cérémonie
à la maison de la suivre sur internet et
il ya des gens qui sont prévenus sont
postés oui à la télévision évidemment
des gens qui sont postés aux différentes
barrières et qui compte littéralement le
nombre de personnes qui sont admis sur
le site on a considérablement limité la
foule aujourd'hui l'appel a clairement
été entendus parce qu'il ya peu de gens
qui semblent se présenter aux bailleurs
et c'est assez inhabituel parce que les
rues autour du monument commémoratif de
guerre du canada qui sont normalement
monde et de 2,2 dans deux genres de
canadiens de ta vie' mais des gens qui
viennent d'un peu partout à travers la
province à travers le pays aujourd'hui
sont complètement déserte je vous le
disais on a réduit l'ampleur de la foule
donc il ya qu une centaine de personnes
qui seront admis sur le site devant le
monument commémoratif de guerre
c'est évidemment pandémie oblige il ya
plusieurs des couronnes que vous voyez
normalement être déposées les gerbes de
fleurs qui sont déjà placés devant le
monument et il n'y a que huit
dignitaires canadiens 8 groupes qui vont
manipuler en fait qui vont représenter
le qui vont déposer une couronne mais
qu'ils ne feront pas physiquement ce
sera fait par quelqu'un qui sera chargé
déplacer la gerbe de fleurs une idée
évidemment là dedans c'est de limiter
les contacts de limiter le nombre de
personnes
qui sont appelés à toucher certains de
ces instruments d'aujourd'hui pour
limiter la propagation de la pandémie
il ya plusieurs éléments de la cérémonie
qui ont été carrément annulée
notamment le fameux défilé les anciens
combattants c'est un moment toujours
tellement émouvant way qui est qui qui
est probablement je vous dirai le moment
le plus marquant de cette cérémonie
quand on voit ces vétérans quand on voit
ces sentiers combattants défilé avec
cette droiture que cette fierté autour
du monument sous les applaudissements
généralement très très nourris du public
alors par défiler aujourd'hui une
trentaine de vétérans au fait qu'ils
seront ici pour représenter les
différents groupes qui sont pour la
plupart déjà déjà arrivé notre chorale
non plus de jeunes qu'on y en a chaque
année pour pour chanter l'hymne au champ
d'honneur
une fanfare militaire considérablement
réduite aussi on dit qu'elle a été
coupée de moitié
et évidemment ce moment à la fin de la
cérémonie où les gens viennent déposer
leurs coquelicot sur la tombe du soldat
inconnu d'encore évidemment cette année
ça n'aura pas lieu la pandémie ici comme
dans bien d'autres sphères a imposé ses
règles cette année très bien l'en
remercie daniel on va vous retrouver un
petit peu plus tard comme je le disais
tout au long de cette cérémonie à défaut
d'être sur place qui est à la maison
installée vous vous allez pouvoir vivre
cet hommage à ottawa en direct avec nous
alors je vous présente tout de suite mes
invités marie-eve vaillancourt halle et
historienne affilié au centre du lot
beach ça c'est le musée qui construisent
sur la plage sont débarqués les
canadiens en juin 1944 à courseulles sur
mer
madame vaillancourt bonjour bonjour et
rémi landry vous le connaissez bien
lieutenant-colonel à la retraite
monsieur landry bonjour bonjour on note
des looks
alors en ce 11 novembre on honore la
signature de l'armistice qui a mis fin à
la première guerre mondiale en 1918 mais
rémy c'est une journée de mémoire
d'hommage aux anciens combattants mais
est-ce que c'est pas beaucoup plus
difficile quand la plupart ne sont pas
présents sont tellement peu nombreux
aujourd'hui mais tout à fait raison
il faut que les gens réalisent que c'est
le moment durant l'année où tous des
anciens camarades se mettant ensemble
donc déjà qu'on voit pas quotidiennement
donc le fait de pour retrouver cette
camaraderie là et puis ensemble de de se
remémorer les bons moments puis surtout
de penser à ceux de nos camarades qui
sont plus là définitivement ça doit
affecter beaucoup de jeu ouais mais il
ya beaucoup de commémoration qui ont
déjà été annulés en raison de la
pandémie on peut penser au 8 mai dernier
qui marquait la fin de la deuxième
guerre en europe mana vaillancourt ça
n'a pas été si lignée souligné on n'a
pas signé non plus la fin de la guerre
au japon
quel est l'impact sur le travail de
mémoire et bien c'est vrai que notre
volonté de vouloir se rassembler lors de
ces moments là elle est très forte et on
s'en rend compte quand on nous enlève
l'occasion de le faire toutes les
efforts qui sont déployés pour remplacer
pour modifier pour faire comme si
c'était normal mais autrement c'est vrai
qu'on voit que le digital pris une très
grande place pour essayer de mais on
sent que on a l'impression qu'on n'a pas
vécu le moment parce que il n'y a pas eu
de rassemblement pour le 8 mai 45
donc c'est vrai que nos cérémonies nous
servent énormément on aura tout ce qui
est invisible reste de l'année
soudainement visible pendant 11 novembre
donc l'incapacité de se rassembler
malgré toutes les prouesses digital
qu'on peut faire ça ne remplace pas le
fait d'être ensemble ouais ouais c'est
ça qui est difficile rémy pour les pour
les anciens combattants qui souvent
peuvent se retrouver isolés ils l'ont
peut-être était davantage encore en plus
encore à cause de la quand pandémie
effectivement je suis qu'au niveau de
l'ensemble des légions les diverses
légion l'étendue du pays c'est des lieux
de rassemblement pour les anciens
militaires les anciens membres de la grc
aussi et puis c'est une occasion de
maintenir ces dix là avec certains de
nos camarades et puis comme vous le
savez bombe à des légions sont fermés au
québec qui peut croire la motion en
ontario donc c'est un autre un autre
aspect qui rend encore une fois le
contact très difficile en six camarades
pendant qu'on voit bien sûr des images
il force aux 5000 canadiennes qui sont
rassemblés donc les quelques personnes
qui sont présentes aujourd'hui pour
cette cérémonie qui doit débuter à 11h
la cérémonie officielle débute à 11h on
attend bien sûr la gouverneure générale
julie payette ainsi que le premier
ministre justin trudeau qui seront
présents à cette cérémonie au monument
commémoratif de guerre donc a été
construit en fait comme réponse c'est
lui qui pour pour symboliser la réponse
du canada à la première guerre mondiale
est là vous voyez ces images de la tombe
du soldat inconnu et rémy quand même
cette pandémie elle a aussi eu un impact
direct immédiat en tout cas content très
visible sur les forces armées
canadiennes puisque il ya près de 2000
soldats qui se sont retrouvés en toute
première ligne la dent les ch et celle
des du québec et de l'ontario
effectivement faut peut-être se rappeler
que dès le début de la pandémie
il ya des directives qui ont été passées
de façon à limiter le nombre de
militaires sur les bases pour
éventuellement les gens demeurent chez
eux soit protégé du covan au virus
et puis éventuellement être en mesure de
desservir temps pour combattre la
pandémie causse y avait des troupes qui
avaient été mis de côté aussi pour faire
face aux inondations printanières
donc ça aussi ça le ajouté je veux dire
à la lourde 1
deux des tâches habituellement rempli
par les militaires parce que malgré tout
ça il faut que les gens réalisent que
nos militaires doivent maintenir un
certain niveau d'entraînement de façon à
pouvoir répondre aux exigences de nos
missions à l'étranger aussi
ouais bien sûr évidemment cette
cérémonie elle souligne en particulier
le 75e anniversaire de la deuxième
guerre mondiale qui a pris fin donc en
mai 45 en europe mais ils sont quand
même de moins en moins nombreux ce
qu'ils ont vécu
on disait déjà depuis quelques temps
qu'ils avaient plus d'anciens
combattants qui avaient combattu pendant
la première guerre mondiale
est ce la deuxième guerre mondiale on en
perd un petit peu d'année en année on
pourrait peut-être voir d'ailleurs les
chiffres 1 2 ce qui reste c'est assez
éloquent parce qu'il ça c'est ceux qui
sont morts au combat pendant la première
guerre mondiale dont vous voyez les
chiffres c'est assez effarant c'est
toujours impressionnant de voir ça 66
plus de 60 civils pendant la première
guerre mondiale
quarante cinq mille soldats qui sont
morts pendant la seconde guerre mondiale
la guerre de corée
la mission de paix et puis tout
dernièrement dans les dernières années
ce qui peut être un peu plus proche de
nous ils sont 58 militaires canadiens
qui sont morts pendant la
dans l'afghanistan et ce qui reste voilà
c'est quand même 26200 d'anciens
combattants de la deuxième guerre
mondiale qui reste et qui ont
aujourd'hui en moyenne 1 95 ans la
guerre de corée il en reste encore 5900
ils ont autour de 88 ans et puis les
autres ben il y en a quand même beaucoup
qui reste 600 1200 qui ont en moyenne 58
60 ans ça nous ça nous attriste toujours
ces chiffres mala vaillancourt quand on
voit qu'ils sont de moins en moins
nombreux
d'où l'importance justement de ce devoir
de mémoire
oui mais quand on pense que il ya eu un
retour massif des soldats d'europe en
1945 au canada il était près d'un
million de canadiens à avoir porté
l'uniforme pendant la seconde guerre
mondiale et là on voit qu'ils en restent
26000 je crois que c'est loc
en comparant la base de service
puisqu'ils nous reste aujourd'hui on
voit bien que c'est à chaque génération
on a un défi incroyable de transmission
intergénérationnelle a relevé chaque
décennie
chaque combat qu'on a mené à l'étranger
que ce soit la première la seconde
guerre mondiale chaque cours de vétérans
si je peux ainsi dire une identité
particulière un vécu des choses
totalement différentes les unes des
autres mais ils ont en commun cette
sensation de frères d'armes qui
financent ces des clés de lecture des
codes de lecture je trouve qu'ils sont
difficiles à comprendre pour le monde
civil qui regarde tout ça un spectacle
un peu bon très protocolaire mais
finalement c'est au monde civil de
s'intéresser d'avoir la curiosité de se
demander mais voilà cette médaille-là
pourquoi qu'est ce qui représente
pourquoi cette personne à la porte et
représente la bosnie l'afghanistan c'est
à nous je pense on a un devoir de
de mémoire un travail de mémoire à faire
de la part du monde civil pour justement
décloisonner le 11 novembre c'est la
seule occasion où on est là en tant que
civil à observer toutes sortes de choses
qu'on comprend pas nécessairement mais
il faut savoir que maintenant
aujourd'hui on a plusieurs générations
de vétérans qui interagissent ensemble
on a pu ceux de la première guerre
mondiale qui d'ailleurs trouvé que les
vétérans de la seconde guerre mondiale
était avait eu une guerre facile par
appareil donc vous voyez il ya tout ce
je pense qu'il faut vraiment
s'intéresser englobe les vétérans dans
une masse assez homogène mais finalement
ce sont des personnes et des groupes
hétérogènes juste et justement parmi
ceux qui vont déposer une couronne tout
à l'heure à la fin de la cérémonie il y
aura madame des bissau lievens et la mer
décorés de la croix d'argent c'est à
dire que c'est une mère qui représentent
toutes celles qui ont perdu un fils ou
une fille au service du canada et son
fils christopher edward saunders a été
tué dans un tragique incendie alors
qu'il servait à bord du ncsm chicoutimi
c'était en 2004
pour elle ce sera bien sûr un honneur
aujourd'hui d'être là mais c'est un
honneur qui portent quand même même
après toutes ces années de très
douloureux souvenirs vous allez voir où
il dit n'être paul nous la présente
des bises sur le pen n'a pas été
surprise lorsque son fils chris saunders
lui annoncé son désir de servir son pays
son fils était un aventurier il choisit
finalement d'être sous mariniers de ce
qui met en 2004 une sortie en mer
tourner au drame
[Musique]
en
chris est mort à la suite d'un incendie
à bord du sous-marin navire canadien de
sa majesté chicoutimi
[Musique]
malgré le temps qui passe son fils est
toujours bien présent dans sa vie
un jour du souvenir débit sur le pen
épinglant sa croix d'argent
crabe seize ans après la mort de son
fils la légion canadienne l'a choisi
comme maire de la croix d'argent
son plus grand réconfort elle le trouve
maintenant dans une école de queen spam
c'est son nouveau brunswick qui porte le
nom de son fils
[Musique]
madame seuls evans qui sera donc
présente pour cette cérémonie et qu'il
ira déposer une couronne au nom de
toutes les mères qui ont perdu un fils
ou une fille dans ces combats ou
ailleurs parce que c'est intéressant
quand même
rémy de voir que maintenant on rend
hommage
pas seulement à ceux qui sont tombés au
combat comme ça a été le cas pendant de
très nombreuses années mais aussi à ceux
qui peuvent comme c'est le cas du fils
de madame sony veulent mourir dans des
accidents parce que ça arrive quand même
assez souvent dans l'armée canadienne
donc on reconnaît ça et on l'a récemment
reconnu aussi les soldats qui sont morts
par suicide par exemple c'est quand même
une ouverture qu'il n'y avait pas il y à
quelques temps encore tout à fait raison
les 20 ans semblent l'oublier mais
chaque année son lot de des scènes qui
sont dus soit des accidents en
préparation choisir une mission et puis
ces gens alors lorsqu'ils le font
lorsqu'ils décèdent ils sont eux mêmes
au service du pays ils le font en
préparation d'une mission ou le
fonctionnement dans l'exercice de leur
tâche
et puis cette année bon 16 0 on a perdu
quelqu'un récemment sur un chantier et
éventuellement un hélicoptère qui s'est
écrasé
ouais en mer ionienne est aussi élu
simard et puis sept capitaines aussi le
qui dans son avion s'est écrasé
lorsqu'elle essayait exactement avec les
snowbirds de faire le tour des
principales villes du canada pour donner
espoir face à la pandémie puis lors
d'une de ces exactement donc
effectivement je veux dire c'est un
endroit aussi d'être connus et puis on
compte depuis 1947 on a fait le décompte
et puis on a plus de 2 700 personnes qui
sont décédées dans avec les opérations
de maintien de la paix dans cet âge là
c'est quand même un nombre assez
considérable c'est assez considérable
chez kci juin et j'imagine qu'on peut
commencer à faire quand même des
parallèles même si c'est difficilement
comparables et à faire des parallèles
madame vaillancourt entre ce que ce
qu'on vit en ce moment cette pandémie
parce qu'on parle beaucoup de sacrifices
on parle beaucoup de l'anxiété que
vivent les canadiens et en se rappelant
de tout ce qu'ont vécu les soldats
pendant les guerres même si je le dis
c'est difficilement comparé mais quand
même il y avait des parallèles à faire
il ya énormément parallèles à faire je
pense que plus qu on connaît l'impact de
la seconde guerre mondiale sur les
canadiens plus on peut faire de
parallèle mais sachez que depuis le
début de la pandémie a jamais eu autant
de références faites au parlement à la
seconde guerre mondiale donc on peut
s'abonner pour recevoir des
notifications au parlement et puis on
peut taper des mots clés et récemment
moi j'ai fait le jeu joué le jeu j'ai
tapé seconde guerre mondiale et puis
j'ai des notifications qui revient et on
le sait françois legault a fait une
référence au coquelicot le 29 octobre
dernier
et c'est vrai que c'est on pense qu'il
n'ya pas très
y'a pas de temps de parallèles à faire
que ça mais finalement je pense qu'on
peut vraiment plus s'identifier
si on sort un jour de cette pandémie on
va en sensations de victoires
incroyables comme on a eu une sensation
de victoire d'avoir vaincu d'avoir
combattu et vaincu pendant la seconde
guerre mondiale aujourd'hui je pense que
quand on va savoir qu' on peut rendre
enfin lever les restrictions une
sensation soulagement incroyable on peut
se projeter donc dans cette sensation de
soulagement qu'ont eue les canadiens en
1945 il ya plusieurs clés de lecture
comme ça qui font qu'on peut
s'approprier un peu mieux l'histoire la
seconde guerre mondiale en ce moment
avec la pandémie
oui mais voilà le premier ministre
justin trudeau et son épouse qui arrive
donc pour ces cérémonies en attendant
les prochaines minutes je vous le disais
la gouverneure générale julie payette
pour cette cérémonie officielle qui
débute à 11h alors il était accompagné
de sa femme sophie grégoire trudeau il
est accueilli
entre autres par le président de la
légion de la légion d'honneur canadienne
jean canadienne par janet evans le chef
d'état major de la défense est aussi
présent le ministre des anciens
combattants le mc cauley hier monsieur
trudeau justement annoncé que le
gouvernement du canada va investir 20
millions de dollars dans la création
d'un fonds d'urgence à l'appui des
organismes de danse un combattant un
fonds qui conçu pour aider les
organismes à continuer de fournir des
services pour soutenir les vétérans qui
ont été touchés par la crise
parce que bien sûr certains ont été
attrapés lakovic 19 d'autres en sont
morts bref les besoins sont quand même
très important pour les anciens
combattants cette période difficile pour
tout le monde mais peut-être difficile
en particulier pour les plus anciens
anciens combattants parce qu'ils sont
évidemment plus vulnérables on le sait à
cette maladie
s'il fait permettre d'ajouter aussi le
problème provient du fait que les
démarches requises pour avoir accès à
ces services là nécessite des rencontres
avec des médecins nécessité rencontres
avec divers services et pour cause de
pandémie
ces services là ne sont pas disponibles
donc que des gens qui devraient obtenir
de l'aide qu'ils peuvent pas l'obtenir
parce qu'ils ont peu accès à ces
services l'ocs pour avoir la
documentation requise pour
éventuellement à pousser leur corps et
puis obtenir les services des anciens
combattants alors dans quelques instants
on attend madame
deby seuls even donc la mer nationales
de la croix d'argent pendant qu'on voit
des images de monsieur trudeau qui est
en train de discuter avec les quelques
personnes présentes j'ai aperçu aussi
quelques quelques personnes qui sont
venus quand même voir malgré les
interdictions qui sont quand même venus
voir cette cérémonie tout à l'heure donc
voilà madame davis olivennes qui
arrivent et qui va être avec son
conjoint donc souvent c'est un moment
émouvant pour les canadiens c'est
l'occasion d'applaudir cette femme pour
lui rendre hommage
mais ça ne se fera pas maintenant car
vous voyez c'est quand même assez
frappant de voir ses rues vides et alors
qu'on a l'habitude de les voir tellement
bondés en cette journée malgré le froid
malgré souvent la neige mais en général
il ya beaucoup de monde donc madame sol
even qui est accueillie c'est le la
cette tradition là si je peux me
permettre d'y revenir un peu elle est
très particulière aucun danger
j'ai regardé un peu
ce qui se passe ailleurs dans le monde
mais ce que d'autres pays ont une mère
comme ça qui représente toutes les mers
et puis la grande bretagne en apple
australie non plus donc c'est assez
émouvant de voir ça c'est un moment qui
pour moi c'est vraiment sans être
présent pendant qu on annonce l'arrivée
de la gouverneure générale julie payette
le gouverneur général c'est bien sûr le
commandant en chef des forces
canadiennes et elles portent l'uniforme
comme le veut la tradition elle choisit
l'uniforme qu'elle va porter pour cette
cérémonie
et on va on nous dit qu'elles portent
cette année celui de la marine royale
canadienne donc on va le voir dans
quelques instants
m
[Musique]
l'action de 50 ans
un pari
la main général en une forme de la
marraine accueillis par la légion royale
canadienne est maintenant escorté vers
l'estrade après avoir dit un mot
distanciation sociale oblige de loin à
chacun des dignitaires qui sont là elle
sera escorté à l'estrade pour recevoir
le salut vis royal c'est la quatrième
cérémonie du souvenir pour jenny palette
payette à titre de gouverneure générale
[Musique]
elle est accueillie par sophie grégoire
trudeau par justin trudeau
madame payet qui vit des moments un peu
difficiles à rideau hall ces temps ci
qui s'adresse maintenant à la mer à la
croix d'argent à madame soleil jeunes
elle va maintenant recevoir le salut
juste royal comme le veut la tradition
[Musique]
et
agl top
et la cérémonie va débuter dans quelques
instants c'est une cérémonie très
différentes on l'a dit puisque le nombre
d'invités le long de personnes présentes
est très restreint c'est la même chose
pour la fanfare les vétérans il y en a
très peu
mais ce sera une seule nuit une
cérémonie solennelle comme toujours avec
la sonnerie aux morts les deux minutes
de silence l'acte de souvenirs dreams
money telle qu'on la connaît et en même
temps très différente dans la mesure où
ceux à qui on rend hommage ne sont pas
présents et évidemment ça change
complètement l'aspect la signification
de tout ça mais il regarde la plupart
des anciens combattants regarde sans
doute sol de chez eux ou sur internet le
public aussi et il y avait un défilé
aérien qui devait remplacer le
traditionnel défilé des vétérans mais
même ça a dû être annulée en raison des
conditions météo alors voilà on va
regarder cette cérémonie on va se
retrouver tout de suite après avec mes
invités à tout de suite
ma
oui les ngn romaine ok mesdames et
messieurs au canada avec des membres de
la musique centrale des forces armées
canadiennes et des akan et du choeur des
enfants d'ottawa
un don
au
je
ton
ses portes
wheels
ton histoire
[Musique]
tournon
oui
non
oh
[Musique]
p
abba
[Musique]
enfin
oh
bon
en
ans
[Musique]
oh
bon
en
non
[Musique]
m
nous ne viendrons pas comme nous qui
leur avons serré qu ils ne connaîtront
jamais le courage ni le poids des années
quand viendra le crépuscule et c'est
drôle nous nous souviendrons d'eux
khedama gee gees tsx kos yann d'ascq et
jy ap teasing candidats cahuita mosic
angie a pété wayne à cjce et au saut les
barres nacac que des pagaies limagne
happiness is magic kids à ce dj bawa cac
cas mam est donnée n'est megan caiga
données d'oméga
vous
today wellwood aujourd'hui nous aurions
aimé leur assemblée en plus grand nombre
en personne afin d'honorer le service et
le sacrifice d'un si grand nombre son
nom de la liberté de la presse
il nous le faut le faire chacun en soit
avec une distance physique mais cela ne
diminue en rien notre gratitude je ne
dis rien l'inspiration que l'on ressent
devant cet exemple ont été les destinées
de ses héros on y ressent dans le coeur
et de la liberté de conscience de chacun
et chacune
je vous invite à prendre moment de
recueillement today we guertin
aujourd'hui nous rendons grâce aux
hommes et aux femmes de chaque
génération qui ont répondu à l'appel du
service au pays
un maire dans les airs ou sur terre chez
nous ou à l'étranger
grâce à ce qu'ils continuent de servir
sous les drapeaux
nous ne tenons pas pour acquis les
sacrifices consentis par ceux qui ont
donné leur vie pour nom en cette année
qui marque le 75e anniversaire de la fin
de la bataille de l'atlantique et des
jours de la victoire en europe et au
japon
nous nous souvenons des marins des
soldats et des aviateurs qui ont été
déployés pour la cause de la paix
puissions nous rendre grâce pour la
détermination la force et la volonté qui
leur furent nécessaires pour faire face
aux terribles épreuves de la guerre et
les web gratuite ue27 avec gratitude que
nous rappelons de nouveaux vétérans et
des militaires qui souffrent ou qui ont
souffert que ce soit des lésions
corporelles spirituel ou de l'esprit
puissions-nous ressentir de la
compassion à ceux qui ont mis fin à
leurs jours
ceux pour lesquels la souffrance était
si grande et le désespoir si lourd sur
leur destin dan et wê board fine euros
qu'ils n'ont pu retrouver un espoir en
l'avenir
nous nous rappelons 2 nous prions pour
les dirigeants de ce monde et de notre
pays on notre souveraine elizabeth ii
reine du canada
la gouverneure générale le premier
ministre et le chef d'état major de la
défense
rassemblons pour affirmer ensemble notre
détermination
[Musique]
which des vibes de combler les clivages
entre nous le racisme les attitude
haineuse et le recours à la violence
oui si j'aurais moved by nous voudrions
supprimer les barrières
supprimer les barrières de la division
dans un esprit de réconciliation au
service de tout un chacun
ce jour quand tu en as changé depuis la
dernière fois qu'on s'est vus ici
puissions nous trouver au réconfort dans
les paroles de sa majesté la reine aux
canadiens dans le contexte même de cette
pandémie actuelle l'espoir devra être
perçue dans les soins offerts aux
vulnérables entre nous ceux qui sont
dans le besoin
l'espoir est à être perçue est ressentie
dans les soins prodigués à ceux d'entre
nous qui sommes vulnérables ceux d'entre
nous qui sommes dans le besoin
puissions nous retrouver l'espoir de
réserver c'est le sacrifice consenti par
ceux qui se sont offert au nom de la
nation au nom de leurs confrères leurs
consoeurs of night always car les
ténèbres nocturne finissent toujours à
l'aube et le jour nouveau puissions-nous
oeuvrer en ce sens
amen
les entreprises mesdames et messieurs le
cortège vis royal déposera maintenant
les couronnes
canada julie payette la gouverneure
générale du canada son excellence la
très honorable
julie bryant
[Musique]
deux nageurs sur le crossover mais se
débarrasse sans nouvelles
la mère nationales de la croix d'argent
madame brown se renouvelle
[Musique]
on
on a besoin d'eux
sentrigo représentant le gouvernement du
canada
notre premier ministre le très honorable
justin trudeau
[Musique]
voilà le premier ministre trudeau qui
vient de déposer ce la couronne au nom
du gouvernement canadien avant lui la
gouverneure générale et la mer à la
croix d'argent ont fait de même
maintenant les autres dignitaires devra
le faire à leur tour et pendant qu'on
entend la musique centrale des forces
armées canadiennes qui interprète au
champ d'honneur
ce qui était ce qui est généralement
interprétée par
la chorale des enfants d'ottawa et bien
on va aller rejoindre mon collègue
daniel thibault qui a assisté à tout ça
et daniel on va pas vous avez pu parler
à quelqu'un de la légion parce que
évidemment le confinement la fermeture
des filiales ça représente un énorme
défi auquel fait face la légion et vous
avez pu vous allez nous présenter
quelqu'un qui en sait quelque chose
voilà sur deux planches vous irez céline
et aujourd'hui on pense évidemment
beaucoup aux anciens combattants et aux
vétérans
ces gens là le reste de l'année souvent
ils se rencontrent dans ses légions sont
dans nos communautés un peu partout à
travers le pays est un point de
ralliement seul endroit où peuvent
rencontrer d'anciens camarades d'armes
avec qui ils sont en mesure j'ai leur
histoire de partager leurs soucis aussi
par moments en ré videmment la pandémie
a frappé de ce côté là et les légions
les salles elles ont été fermés pendant
une bonne partie de l'année et ça aussi
considérablement gruger aux mines et la
capacité de les organisations la
accueillir des fonds amasser des fonds
qui permettent de payer pour les
opérations régulières
j'ai rencontré joyce brisson c'est la
porte parole de la légion canadienne
dans la région d'orléans c'est un peu à
l'est d'ottawa
elle va nous parler de ce que ça
représente comme défi la fermeture ou la
pandémie pour les légions un peu partout
au canada
just bonjour c'est être avec des gens
gagnant pour le commun des mortels si
peut-être pas claire ce qui se passe
dans une dans une région qu est ce qu
est ce qui se raconte ce qui est coincé
coin l'histoire ce qu'est ce qu'ils
viennent d'unir ces jeunes ils viennent
raconter leur histoire de leur vécu
dante inquiétèrent en service de tous en
général vraiment mais c'est plutôt leur
vécu durant leur service
des forces c'est dur donc pour eux ne
pas avoir ce forum la créature très très
dur déjà voulons discuter d'une c'est
dur c'est une zone 6 est triste c'est
c'est dur pour les autres passent comme
je dis c'est une famille alors pour les
autres ces rassemblements peut-être une
fois par semaine de venir puis jeu ce
soir puis est capable de jaser beaucoup
de ces gens là sont seuls alors ça lui a
fait une place pour nous est peut être
capable de rencontrer d'autres gens
parlons du du coquelicot parce que ça
aussi c'est une portion importante du
jour souligne la des fonds qui sont
ramassés grâce à cette heure c'est un
signe là cette effigie là par les balles
et moi de ce que c'est d'habitude de ce
que ce sera cette année les fendu du
coquelicot post branche si l'année
passée on avait renoncé 106 1000 cette
année le but et 58 mille parce qu'on n'a
pas la même eu le même genre de vente
qu'aux horaires en temps normal
qu'est ce que vous faites avec c'est un
jour cet argent leur est servi pour
aider les vétérans dans le besoin alors
le fond du coquelicot hyde
c'est jean loup dans le temps les
régions dans l'est dans la région des
vétérans dans le besoin cesser vous
voulez dire quoi ce des vétérans qui ont
besoin de ces fonds là pourquoi pays
leurs ouailles it manger des paiements
des ménages de la base la cdc des
dépenses de base c'est ça l'argent pas
servi pour un luxe l'agent est servi
pour aider les vétérans le sens combien
116000 des données sans cesse mais
l'année dernière 58 ans regarde pour 58
milles cette année c'est ça aussi la
cible mais vous n'êtes pas là
présentement comme celle au dernier
comptage on était rendu à 18 milles 550
600 mille de moins ce qu'est ce qui
arrive
qu'est ce qui arrive aux gens qui ont
besoin de cet argent là quand il manque
100 me mais disons que ça sera
probablement pas facile à joindre les
mêmes bus ils vont faire qu'est ce
qu'ils peuvent avec commandiez il va
falloir faire
qu'est ce qu'on peut avec ce qu'on a
mais des gens qui vont avoir besoin est
des gens qui auront pas d'être ya des
gens qui vont manquer d'être c'est sûr
qui comprend pas aidé le même nombre de
gens avec le 100 mille de moins cette
année il ya beaucoup de gens qui seront
pas décerné de la même façon merci
oui oui c'est difficile peut-être deux
ou trois belles notes à travers tout ça
le gouvernement hier a annoncé
l'injection de fait millions de dollars
pour aider les vétérans il ya 14
millions qui ira directement légion
ensuite dans le cas de la légion
d'orléans
quand les salles ont dû fermer ils ont
organisé à l'idée d'un bénévole d'une
collecte de bouteilles et imaginer au
cours des derniers mois ils ont
recueilli dix mille dollars dans la
communauté
c'est quand même pas mal ça va leur
permettre de traverser les prochains
mois m'a dit madame bisson hier et puis
dernière étape vous savez les ventes de
coquelicots qui ont particulièrement
gréve et la capacité de lever des fonds
hier quand on est allé rencontrer madame
bisson durant la petite heure et demie
où on était là ils ont ramassé ils ont
amassé en vendant des coquelicots et
d'aider des produits de la légion dans
le lobby de l'édifice ils ont ramassé
1300 $ il ya un appel qui a été lancé
est clairement les gens m'ont entendu
bon match sûr que là on entend dans ce
que vous êtes entrevue il ya des gens
aussi qui vont se manifester
merci beaucoup daniel à tout à l'heure
les yeux je retrouve tout de suite nous
invité mario vaillancourt donc
historienne au centre juno beach et rémi
landry donc rémy une réaction peut-être
parce qu'on vient d'entendre on se rend
compte à quel point cette campagne du
coquelicot est importante pour les
anciens combattants
peut-être nous rappelait justement d'où
vient ce coquelicot ans à vienne un
poème en fait ça vient d'eux d'un d'un
poème du lieutenant colonel john may cry
c'est ça qui était médecin
durant la première guerre mondiale et
puis lors de la perte d'un de ces de ses
camarades décidé d'écrire ce poème la 18
en 1915
et puis il le trouvait pas tellement
beau il le jeter et puis ça a été
recueilli par un ses collègues
et puis on sait aujourd'hui que la
popularité internationale de ce poème là
qui étaient traduits en plusieurs
langues
et puis aussi qu'ils étaient chantés
mais pour revenir à la légion si je veux
juste me permettre je dois vous dire que
depuis déjà cinq ans je me fais un
devoir personnel de vendre des
coquelicots
c'est une façon aussi de se rapprocher
des gens de parler avec les jambes à
cause de pandémie cette année c'est
impossible d'avoir des vétérans aux
divers endroits où les coquelicots été
vendus et c'est ce qui explique en
grande partie le fait qu'on n'est pas en
mesure de recueillir autant d'argent
qu'on a l'habitude de le faire
je trouve que c'était un élément très
important parce que ça nous met en
contact avec des jeunes qui n'ont pas
osé question et puis type garneau
médaille qui nous regardent c'est quoi
différence et vous avez été
et puis ma grande surprise je trouve
toujours que oui les jeunes sont très
généreux oui
généreux vous êtes tous à vous aimer
mais là je vais juste je vous interromps
une seconde pour remonte pour parler de
ces images que l'on voit donc c'est le
président donald trump qui a fait une
première sortie en fait depuis son
depuis la la soirée électorale
donc monsieur jobs qui est venu rendre
hommage d'anciens combattants au
cimetière d'arlington
je trouve qu'on ne voit pas beaucoup ces
temps ci puisqu'il est à la maison
blanche et qu'il refuse de reconnaître
la victoire de joe biden donc monsieur
trump
cimetière d'arlington donc oui cette
campagne du coquelicot très importante
vous le disais
et qui existe en grande bretagne qui
existe dans certains autres pays mais
pas partout dans le monde et pas une
tradition qui existe en france par
exemple madame vaillancourt
oui mais le 11 9 en mai est célébré en
france mais il représente surtout
la première guerre mondiale uniquement
ah oui donc c'est vrai qu'au canada on a
une particularité c'est que quand
l'armistice est devenu le jour du
souvenir en 1931 on avoue on a ouvert
les portes parce que cette journée là
puisse être aussi d'autres guerres et
comme je disais tout à l'heure c'est une
transmission générationnelle donc à
chaque fois qu'il ya un nouveau conflit
on rajoute on le voit dans le monument
aux morts à ottawa il ya 14 18 89 45 et
ainsi de suite donc c'est quelque chose
qui est très ouvert et très inclusif
je pense notamment au discours du de
l'aumônier général
j'ai vraiment fait référence reconnaître
la souffrance on envoie un signal clair
à tous ceux qui arrivent au canada qui
migrent au canada que voilà on vous
interrompre parce que ce sont ces le
temps des bénédictions va écouter et je
reviens de suite après l'année en cours
le sacrifice consenti par tant de
canadiens et les sacrifices qu'ils
étaient prêts à consentir au maire dans
les airs comme sur les terres nous
sommes à la gratitude face aux disparus
aux blessés use et pleurer les hommes et
les femmes anglophones francophones
autochtone ans un combattant qui font
partie de tant de communautés
culturelles différentes
les anciens combattants jeunes musée
vieux présent de façon virtuelle mais
dans l'unité et dans le respect
réciproque dans l'admiration mutuelle
nous sommes vraiment emprunt de
gratitude d'avoir mis vos vies de coûter
devoir me vous vie en péril pour
combattre sereni défend la liberté
nous applaudissons votre vaillance au
combat votre intrus a semé votre et
traite de la nation vous êtes des héros
et des héroïnes et vous méritez notre
gratitude éternelle nous sommes pas un
gars mais nous luttons pour notre santé
collective et individuelle et nous
sommes ensemble dans cette lutte
c'est une lutte que nous le pouvons
gagner ensemble
ceux d'entre nous celles d'entre nous
n'ont pas connu la guerre avant et avait
une meilleure idée de ce que c'est que
d'être au loin séparer de ces êtres
chers chacun maintenant le vit on n'a
pas choisi cette séparation
ce sont des circonstances du destin qui
nous l'imposent
nos anciens combattants nos anciennes
combattantes qui sont présents dans nos
mémoires ont choisi de se battre pour
notre pays pour notre liberté
sachant que cela les séparerait de leur
famille et dans bien des cas tragiques
une séparation tout à fait permanente en
guerre on est souvent de 20 ennemis
qu'on ne voit pas un ennemi camoufler
dissimulé cela prend un effort collectif
pour surmonter ses effets culte et aux
combats on sait que ses analogues avec
la coved quand les installations de
soins collecte ces fentes en difficulté
à qui on a fait appel à nos soldats qui
a répondu à l'appel
sans lui tout être a freiné par le
danger nos soldats et qui de nouveau
offert en temps de crise nationale
son temps le soldat et qui était sur la
première ligne coude à coude avec nous
travailleuses héroïque de la santé et
oui nos soldats et nos soldates
dans notre mémoire collective en ce jour
du souvenir existe le dévouement sans
faille de notre ancien combattant de
notre ancienne combattante
on le ressent profondément aujourd'hui
on donne du sens concret à ce qu'on
entend dans l'hymne national c'est à
dire qu'on va se tenir debout pour vous
à l'attention et à la différence des
années précédentes on s'en rappelle
particulièrement car qu'on sache ou non
aujourd'hui nous sommes tous des soldats
dans l'équipe canada ce rôle c'est de
sauver des vies en agissant de façon
responsable en suivant le modèle de
lettre hui sme présenté par les anciens
combattants continuent de faire en sorte
que le canada soit digne de leur
sacrifice un pays définis par le respect
l'harmonie l'inclusion et la
responsabilité
sans oublier la décence et la bonté
envers chacun chacune
que dieu bénisse notre pays nous troupes
et tous ceux et celles qui se tiennent
prêts à être des champions et des
champions de la paix de la sécurité de
la santé de la tranquillité que dieu
bénisse le canada amen
ladies and gentlemen mesdames et
messieurs que dieu protège la reine avec
maria giulini du coeur des enfants
d'ottawa et pour marquer le 75e
anniversaire de la fin de la seconde
guerre mondiale un défilé aérien
d'avions d'époque conclure à la
cérémonie
ce
m
je
sous
et
[Musique]
voilà c'est la fin de cette cérémonie on
nous avait on vient nous annoncer que le
défilé aérien allait avoir lieu mais on
nous avait dit un peu plus tôt qu'il
serait à nous pas nous y voilà on est en
train de la danse et que finalement
c'est bien annulée à cause des
conditions météo et un peu trop de vent
pour ces anciens appareils qui ont servi
pendant la deuxième guerre mondiale pour
voler c'est un peu difficile avec ce
genre de temps alors on a vu une
cérémonie bien différentes cette année
étrange ans que cet hommage aux vétérans
se fasse sans la présence de deux
anciens combattants sans se défiler
surtout de ses anciens combattants sur
un moment de très grande fierté pour eux
chaque année de pouvoir défiler comme ça
dans les rues d'ottawa devant un public
qui est toujours très enthousiaste alors
tout ça évidemment dans une
signification un peu particulier à une
couleur un peu particulière à ces
commémorations et au travail de mémoire
alors je vais retrouver mes invités rémy
malo vaillancourt rémy d'abord est ce
que c'est la première fois qu'on voit
comme ça une cérémonie selon vos
souvenirs sans 100 anciens combattants à
ma connaissance c'est effectivement la
première fois je veux me jetait pas là
avant les des années 40 je peux pas
parler de ces années l'homme est depuis
au moins 60 et vite
c'est la première fois que je joue à une
cérémonie qui a été grandement limité à
cause de la pandémie
puis je suis bien apprécié les prières
du durable qui est actuellement été en
mesure de faire le lien entre la guerre
et la guerre qu'on mène actuellement
contre la coved 19
et puis de mettre l'emphase sur le nous
parce que c'est avec nous qu'on va être
en mesure de pouvoir vaincre ce que 8,19
la wii pendant qu'on voit les images de
la gouverneure générale qui s'apprête à
quitter bientôt la place de la
confédération et qu'ils discutent avec
les quelques personnes qui sont
présentes oui mais vous parlez de ce
nous donc madame vaillancourt vous en
avez vous l'avez évoqué un peu plus tôt
et en même temps ce parallèle là qu'on
peut faire entre peut-être la deuxième
guerre mondiale
est ce qu'on vit en ce moment et oui et
tout à fait c'est c'est sûr que comme
l'a mentionné
le ravin durant son discours il étale
bien les valeurs qui animent ce qu'ils
ont besoin de servir pour les autres et
là c'est l'occasion vraiment parfaite
pour faire toutes sortes de liens puiser
en la seconde guerre mondiale je crois d
exemple de résilience qu'on peut
appliquer à novi maintenant aujourd'hui
je pense que on le voit aussi par la
présence de cette mère finalement qui
est qui est un geste extrêmement
symbolique quand je le rappelais tout à
l'heure vous le canada est un des seuls
pays qui a fait ce geste là cette façon
là donc on retrouve dès le premier
ministre des hauts gradés
le commandant en chef des forces
canadiennes et puis une mère comme ça
qu'ils viennent du nouveau brunswick
vécu toute une vie dans le service qui
est d'ailleurs elle même enseignante si
je me rappelle bien qu' une famille de
militaires donc c'est absolument
phénoménale de voir qu'on peut mélanger
des symboles comme ça de la vie
quotidienne de gens tout simple à côté
dans le premier ministre et moi je
trouve que la présence de cette femme et
de ce geste du canada on voit que à
chaque année il ya une marque qui est
représenté comme ça c'est très
particulier quand n'ont pas droit aux
hommages également rendu hommage aux
anciens combattants bien sûr à ceux qui
sont tombés au combat mais on rend
hommage aussi à la population en fait
aux familles qui ont consenti tous ces
sacrifices aussi voilà parce que quand
on prend la peine de regarder un peu les
incidents les histoires de ces gens là
on se rend bien compte que les faits les
conséquences dans leur famille sont
incroyables et c'est vrai qu'en ce
moment en étant pandémie il y a des
conséquences dans nos familles donc le
parallèle est tout à fait le bris oui on
la voit là madame sony veine qui disait
un peu plus tôt dans son entrevue à quel
point c'était un honneur pour elle de
représenter toutes les mères du pays et
en même temps un moment toujours
difficile et pourtant son fait sain est
décédé en 2004 donc le temps passe mais
la douleur elle reste toujours toujours
il c'est un club auquel elle est
heureuse d'appartenir mais comme je le
disais tout à l'heure qu elle n aurait
jamais souhaité appartenir à ce club de
marc nationales de croix d'argent
le projet vise aussi qui va qui va dire
moi madame se leva louis rémy je voulais
juste mentionné qu'il faut dire que le
statut
demain demeuré pendant un an jusqu'au
1er novembre de l'année prochaine
et puis au cours de cette année là bas
la légion va lui demander de contribuer
éventuellement à propager le message
qu'elle représente comme étant la mère
militants alors parlant des défis que
cette pandémie amène au niveau des
commémorations parce qu'évidemment on
parle beaucoup du devoir de mémoire
cette journée du 11 novembre ça nous
permet justement de parler de ces grands
conflits de parler du rôle du canada et
de des efforts consentis par le canada
dans ces grandes guerres et dans celle
qu'ont suivie à quel point ça complique
les choses parce que beaucoup de
commémoration qui ont dû être annulées
en cette année quel a été l'impact
alain vaillancourt réseaux sociaux ce
matin j'ai vu qu'il ya une dame qui a
dessiné un énorme coquelicot qui permet
un vétéran dans sa résidence de
personnes âgées de regarder de haut et
de voir cet énorme coquelicot donc on
voit bien que les gens ont besoin de
signaler à ceux qui sont isolés à ceux
qui ont besoin de voir que la population
civile
remarque cette journée là donc j'ai
trouvé ça absolument attendrissant de
voir que ce vétéran la voir se réveiller
en voyant un immense coquelicot dessinée
dans la neige uniquement pour lui donc
c'est un exemple mais je pense que il ya
toutes sortes de façons de rejoindre les
jeunes
monsieur landry le mentionnait tout à
l'heure que les jeunes sont curieux et
ils sont sympathiques naturellement
quand il fait sa campagne de coquelicots
donc nous on a fait un webinar avec un
vétéran de 96,1 on a eu des centaines et
des centaines de questions pour ce
vétéran là
f on a eu à peu près neuf mille
étudiants qui se sont joints à nous pour
écouter ce vétéran là et les questions
étaient absolument phénoménale
empathique intelligente profonde et on
se rend compte que toute cette jeunesse
acquis qui ne demande qu'à comprendre et
à écouter quand on leur donne l'occasion
de s'exprimer ils ont un respect
incroyable
donc c'est vrai que en temps normal on
aurait fait une cérémonie là on a fait
une rencontre virtuelle avec presque 10
mille étudiants est un vétéran donc
impensable avant la pandémie
c'est vraiment une opportunité
incroyable qui nous apporte la pandémie
malheureusement et heureusement welle a
profondément transformé nos façons de
vivre nos rapports avec les autres cette
pandémie et d'ailleurs
les autorités ont été forcés de faire
des choix quand même des choix sans
précédent par exemple il ya des soldats
des forces armées canadiennes qui ont
été déployés dans des cfc l'est du
québec et de l'ontario
ça a été une décision 13 qu'elle fait
une très grosse différence là au québec
danielle thibeault
vous avez rencontré une des volontaires
de ce déploiement hors du commun
commençons par parler de vous caporal
chef martin dites moi qu'est ce que par
les mots de votre carrière en tant que
militaire qu'est ce que vous avez fait
qu'est-ce que vous avez chanté dans
l'effort son origine en dehors
catinot en 2016 j'ai fait mes cours de
bosses avec ma qualification militaire
de bol je finis tout de même formation
ensuite l'armée m'a apporté beaucoup
d'opportunités l'année passée par
exemple j'ai pu déployer sur l'opération
présence qui était au sénégal mali qui
se passait en afrique puis cette année
dernièrement avec les acolytes bien j'ai
pu déployer dans les chu celle des pour
venir en aide aux résidents du vigile
reine elizabeth à montréal l'autre entre
le sénégal et le mali et la vie en
sécher cd il me semble que deux membres
de sénégal le mali ça me semble être
quelque chose de normal pour une
militaire ce à quoi on s'attend non mais
j'imagine oui c'est plus l'emploi
typique notons qu on constate en 2004
ça c'est sûr que quand je rentre dans
les fosses je pensais pas cillé pour 1
journée est d aider des résistants dans
son sillage celle des messes un beau
défi que je suis vraiment content
d'avoir eu la chance de participer
commandes à bord du chemin comment
comment où on voit ça quand on dit parce
que vous vous êtes porté volontaire
pourquoi ben je me disais justement
c'est un beau défi
puis c'était une façon de rejoindre la
population canadienne
autrement fait qu'un juste de venir ici
puis de partager des moments avec ses
pensionnaires qui n'ont pas accès à
leurs familles parce qu'ils sont en
isolement en cause de 10 virus mais nous
on pouvait leur apporter peut-être un
peu d'être de ce côté là le new jersey
avec eux l'aide avec leurs soins
ce n'est pas messi sait pas c'est pas
pour ça que vous avez une formation
non c'est sûr qu'on n'est pas formé pour
revenir dans les chu celle des cas qu'on
a su qu on venait ici on a reçu une
petite formation par l'armée on a reçu
une formation par la croix rouge puis un
courant vie ici on est une formation par
les employés du ch et celle du fait
qu'on vend environ 3 4 jours de
formation mais moi je membres d'équipage
blindés c'est certain que j'ai pas
vraiment les connaissances médicales
requises mais je pense qu'on a très bien
relever le défi se contente de ça il y
avait deux groupes qui sont venus ici il
y avait deux groupes qui étaient formés
à des gens qui allaient aux cuisines ya
des gens qui allaient au nettoyage ou à
la désinfection des d r d vous vous avez
dit moi je peux faire plus je te faire
autre chose avec ac on est arrivé on
s'est fait demander qui était
confortable d'être proche avec les
résidentes d'apporter des soins fait que
j'ai tout lever ma main je me disais que
c'est une bonne opportunité pour moi de
d'avoir des nouvelles connexions avec
les personnes âgées
puis on m'a mis avec l'équipe médicale
fait que j'y vais avec toutes les
tranches de vie quotidienne fait que les
nourrir changer les culottes faire des
douches des douches partiel puis jose
avec eux puis voir comment ils vont
pourquoi vous avez vu votre main vous
êtes dit moi je peux faire pour que je
veux faire ça moi mais j'ai toujours été
intéressé avec tout ce qui est relations
relations et en personnel que j'ai
étudié pour devenir policière jeu dans
l'armée en ce moment qui mon but c'est
d'aider les gens se certain que côté
médical
j'ai pas les qualifications requises
mais juste d'être leur pouvoir partager
ce moment avec avec coeur c'est ce qui
m'a fait comme kiwi je veux lever ma
main puis aller discuter avec eux voir
comment les outils de stockage et l
homélie le talent au sénégal vous avez
vu ce qui s'est passé là bas comment
vous comparez ce que vous avez vécu là
bas par rapport à ce que vous avez vécu
c'est complètement différent c'est
vraiment pas la même terreur
opérationnel ça c'est certain mais si tu
de savoir qu' on est vraiment avec notre
population la population canadienne
c'est ça fait du bien ça fait chaud au
coeur de savoir qu'on peut aider ici au
canada puis j'ai vraiment aimé mon
expérience 6 avec les deux apporté des
défis différents mais dans l'armée on
est entraîné à travailler en équipe
on a beaucoup de disciplines la
résilience mental je pense que c'est
tout des atouts qui m'ont beaucoup aidé
à passer par dessus le défi pendre le
défi dans le fond puis juste réagir puis
s'adapter rapidement et efficacement et
vous du contact avec les familles des
gens dont vous êtes occupé de temps en
temps parce que les résidants avaient le
droit de rouler comme des visites
virtuelles sur ipad avec leur famille
avec des fois j'étais dans la chambre il
y avait leur visite le directeur bien
ici de chaque service et ma fille c'est
mon gars même présentés ont visé des
coucous qui est fait pour les familles
ils étaient super contents de nous voir
aussi en paix nous disons merci d'être
lopy comme ça faisait chaud au coeur a
entendu ce terme iphone un truc ou des
fois on y repense à vouziers
une fois de temps en temps une personne
moment est ce que quelque chose qui vous
a marqué plus que d'autres mais ça
s'appelle il ya quelques résidents avec
lesquels j'ai établi plus de contact
puis ce sera comme avant de
avant de partir quand j'ai fait de ma
tournée je dit bye bye à tout le monde
c'est en avait que j'ai senti qu'ils
étaient très ce qu'on partait vite
c'était ma dernière journée fait que
c'est enfin que ce côté là je pense
encore des fois c'est pour ça que
justement je vais à contacter le ch est
celle du poor s et de revenir faire du
bénévolat ici quand la police arrive
sera fini parce que si on a vraiment des
bons liens humains avec ses personnels
well as caporal-chef chagny mark martin
qui donc était dans les seychelles et
aux seychelles des vigies reine
elizabeth à montréal comme
impressionnant les enfants parce qu'il
faut se souvenir
les conditions qui existaient à ce
moment là dans le ch est celle née au
québec notamment et dans certains sièges
et celle de l'ontario mais quand même
plus de 140 ch et celle du québec
on l'a vu à quel pauvre plus de 40
pardon ses chaussettes des au québec
donc on a vu où on voyait à quel point
c'était chaotique dans les chu celle des
et l'armée est intervenue à un moment
donné c'était absolument essentiel rémi
landry
c'est un côté de l'armée peut-être du
travail des militaires qu'on voit assez
rarement la protection des plus
vulnérables et plus démunis ça a mis en
lumière le travail humanitaire les
capacités humanitaire des forces armées
canadiennes exactement joseph comme le
caporal-chef le mentionner c'est sûr
lorsqu'on est à l'étranger
on se voit surtout dans un rôle de
guerriers dans un rôle de métiers de la
paix mais il ya toujours cette
innovation humanitaire l'eau où les
militaires sont appelés à diverses
occasions de mettre à profit cette
empathie l'appui ses dettes aux gens qui
sont dans le besoin
et puis tout à fait d'accord il de
caporal chef en disant que le faire ici
au canada bombe à ces c'est encore plus
intéressant pour ces militaires nous
parce qu'ils le font pour leurs propres
pour leurs proches
donc bravo tous ces gens alors et puis
ça manque encore une fois je veux dire
la la la la capacité d'être au service
c'est ce qui fait que les gens du moins
pour que je rejoigne des forces armées
canadiennes est au service de l'homme
est au service de notre pays et vous
dites c'est différent de très différent
de raphaël le disait aussi serait
différent de ce qu'on peut vivre au mali
au sénégal ou en bosnie mais où en
afghanistan mais n'empêche que l'armée
canadienne parfois doit intervenir
justement auprès des populations
dans le même genre de rôle mais
évidemment on n'est pas toujours là pour
le voir là vaillancourt
oui mais ce que je remarque est surtout
quand elle parle et c'est cet état
d'esprit là pour on a du mal à
comprendre parfois en tant que civil
c'est que quand on s'engage à servir on
s'engage page blanche
on sais pas qu'est ce qui va nous
arriver qu est ce que à quoi on dit oui
en fait donc c'est cette notion là qu'on
doit bien comprendre que là on est face
à des gens qui disent oui à peu près
voilà ils répondent à l'appel
et c'est incroyable d'avoir la chance de
s'entretenir avec une personne comme ça
et de voir l'impact que cela a sur elle
bravo c'est assez impressionnant en fait
j'étais très ému d'écouter ce témoignage
de cette jeune femme l'un qui on le voit
bien l'état d'esprit ce besoin
dd et c'est dans ces moments-là que face
à l'adversité qu'on vit tous en ce
moment mais le courage ils viennent de
la solidarité et puis voilà c'est tout
c'est aussi simple que ça et nous le
fait bien sentir et l'importance du
d'une ou du collectif en fait on se
retrouve alors comme une société
généralement beaucoup plus
individualiste donc là est ce que vous
pensez que toute cette notion de
sacrifice
pendant qu'on voit la gouverneure
générale qui quittent la place
de la confédération à ottawa donc est ce
que la notion de sacrifice va résonner
un peu plus dans la population vous
pensez rémy probablement mais il faut
continuer de le rappeler c'est ça qui
est important les gens ont oublié le
verglas ou des militaires aussi je veux
dire s'occupait d'évacuer des gens de
certaines maisons de fournir du bois de
chauffage
je me rappelle dans les années soixante
et dix sont lors de grosses tempêtes
dans la région de québec où on sortait
des militaires pour aider des gens qui
étaient pris dans leur voiture c'est
quelque chose qu'il faut rappeler
régulièrement
et puis ces moments là qui nous
permettent de faire comprendre aux gens
que oui on est aussi russes
et puis je crois que comme le rappelle
mentionnait on a une occasion
actuellement le qui nous rapproche tous
ensemble du la guerre quand même touche
contre le lac au vide était en espérant
que ce qu'on retiendra de sauce et c'est
cet événement l'autre solidarité puis
d'entr'aide qu'on a besoin pour passer
au travers
alors on l'a vu tout à l'heure le chef
d'état major de la défense de nature 20
ce qui était bien sûr présent à cette
cérémonie il a annoncé cet été sa
retraite à peu après plus de cinq ans à
la tête des forces armées canadiennes je
pense que c'est le plus long mandat pour
un chef d'état major daniel thibault a
pu parler un peu plus tôt on va
l'écouter
une cérémonie particulière dans un
contexte particulier comment vous
l'abordez cette cérémonie les autres
c'est important toujours 2
d'être ici avec eux
un groupe où souvenez mauvais terrain
c'est un peu différent cette année on
manque de tout le monde mais j'imagine
je suis fier qu'on sous suivi les les
règlements médical mais est-ce que vous
qu'est ce que vous voulez dire aux
vétérans qui peuvent pas être ici
aujourd'hui sont à la maison devant leur
téléviseur devant l'internet
qu'est ce que vous lisez aussi aux gens
qui n'ont malgré ici tout le tour de la
section s'apprend pas une peau neuve est
ici pour mémoriser camonais commémorer
novateur pour novateur à aider des
millions de canadiens dans leur maison
maintenant
[Musique]
ils sont en train de
commémorer leur service service tv
terrain on retiendra donc c'est un
moment de fierté c'est différent mais
c'est un moment que on va être tellement
faire dans des occasions comme celle on
pense beaucoup à la participation des
soldats canadiens dans les grandes
guerres la deuxième guerre mondiale la
première la guerre de corée
on dirait depuis quelques temps que vos
soldats vos forces intervienne davantage
ici on a vu durant les premiers mois de
la pandémie en ch et celle des par
exemple dans les esses que le mandat
votre mandat la façon qu'on va
travailler ça change
non ça change pas daniel
n'oubliez pas que de défense du canada
prendre différentes formes
c'est pas toujours contre un ennemi armé
avec un uniforme
notre mandat est de défendre le canada à
n'importe quel ennemi n'importe quel un
moment ton un panda ni un ennemi
et nous avons pris un rôle important
on
dès qu'un du canada pour défendre des
canadiens et canadiennes en terminant
c'est votre dernière cérémonie sur votre
dernier jour de souvenir vous allez
prendre votre retraite
ce que c'est spécial qu'est ce que vous
ressentez aujourd'hui c'est un peu
sentimental 7
c'est toujours un moment de fierté pour
moi d'être là
le monument est un représentant tous les
membres des forces américaines dans
cette moment de commémoration de semaine
jonathan vance donc le chef d'état major
de la défense qui pour qui c'est la
dernière cérémonie du souvenir puisqu'il
quitte ses fonctions
il a annoncé en juillet dernier outil
toujours pas qui va le remplacer par
ailleurs donc qui a défendu le rôle des
militaires pendant cette pandémie même
si c'est pas nécessairement ce qu'on
attend toujours des militaires mais qui
ont servi un peu dans ce climat très
difficile de la pandémie alors
maintenant on va aller rejoindre mon
collègue pascal point lan qui est à
québec lui pascal donc une cérémonie
également à québec et avec les
restrictions
ça s'est déroulé comment c'était
beaucoup plus à bras aussi ici à québec
n'empêche il ya quand même trois
hélicoptères griffon de la base
militaire de valcartier qui ont survolé
la ville survolé les plaines d'abraham
et puis ensuite borne a entendu le
clairon
entamé la dernière sonnerie a eu deux
minutes de silence puis le premier
ministre françois legault a fait une
courte allocution compétences
aujourd'hui on a un devoir de mémoire
aujourd'hui on se rappelle la onzième
heure du 11e jour du 11e mois en 1918 ou
enfin la première guerre mondiale s'est
terminée aujourd'hui on doit se souvenir
de nos parents grands parents arrière
grands parents qui sont allés défendre
notre liberté dans certains corps
l'autre côté de l'atlantique
ils ont été très courageux
aujourd'hui on dit merci à tous ceux qui
ont combattu à tout ce sont encore dans
les forces armées pour défendre nos
droits notre liberté
aujourd'hui au nom de la nation
québécoise
je ne souviens
les déclarations très fortes du premier
ministre françois legault et pascal il y
avait des vétérans quand même qu'ils ont
tenu à assister à cette cérémonie
oui d'anciens combattants qui étaient là
ils nous ont parlé de l'isolément qu'ils
vivent pas ce qu'ils peuvent plus se
rassembler vous savez ici dans la région
de québec il y en a beaucoup des
militaires à la retraite qui se
rassemblent pour un café une fois par
semaine au coeur des groupes d'entre
elles parce que certains souffrent de
symptômes post traumatiques
là il ne peut plus tenir ces
rassemblements mais il tenait au moins à
être ici bien sûr avec un masque mais
pour ce public prêtre collègue un ami
grains verts où elle a perdu la vie pour
haïti
la mairie
les images de françois legault oui alors
voilà cette émission tire déjà à sa fin
un petit mot peut-être madame
vaillancourt et rémy sur ce que vous
retenez ce qui vous habite un peu vos
réflexions après cette cérémonie
oui déjà moi je trouve que les discours
qu'on entend les symboles qu'on voit
tous ces gestes là qu'ils les traditions
les moments de la cérémonie
la sonnerie aux morts tout ça c'est un
peu cloisonné puis ont du mal à rentrer
là dedans mais cette année j'ai senti
quelque chose de particulier où tous ses
collègues qui sont un peu impénétrable
deviennent beaucoup plus accessible et
on passe beaucoup de temps à décortiquer
d'où viennent nos gestes nos symboles du
11 novembre
et je trouve qu'ils on voit bien qu'ils
évoluent dans le temps pour toujours
être pertinent finalement et ça c'est un
modèle qui est qui est vraiment efficace
en ce moment parce que on a 11 novembre
qui est inclusif et qui met l'accent sur
reconnaître la souffrance des autres et
donc à partir de là on envoie un signal
fort je pense à tous les canadiens ceux
qui viennent d'arriver dans notre pays
je pense à ça aussi notamment où les
souffrances qu'ils ont peut-être quitter
en arrivant ici ils vont pouvoir
s'associer au 11 novembre c'est pas
quelque chose qui est fermé c'est
quelque chose qui évolue et là cette
année on le voit encore plus dans ses
tirs au but où tout le monde et on est
obligé de quitter certains modèles mais
aller vers d'autres rémy je crois que ma
collègue pratiquement tout dit mais je
voudrais juste rajouter que les propos
jijel abeilles l'oeuf selon moi c'est le
fait marquant le marquand excusez-vous
ce qui fait le lien entre la guerre
premier mini laiteries qui est en même
temps et la guerre contre le comité je
crois que cette analogie là je veux dire
parle d'elle-même et puis fait en sorte
que j'ose espérer que l'ensemble des
canadiens vont vont être en mesure de
faire le lien aussi entre ces deux types
b guerdat et puis de réaliser qu'on est
tous tous d'une façon d'un autre affecté
par ces gars là oui comme une cérémonie
way qui a été très émouvante en fait
peut-être justement à cause de sa
sobriété à cause de de tout ce qu'on
sait qui se passe tout ces commentaires
qu'on a entendu aussi sur la difficulté
que vivent les anciens combattants qui
sont toujours avec nous donc marié
vaillancourt historienne affilié au
centre du hall
each et rémi landry lieutenant-colonel à
la retraite
je veux remercier tous les deux d'avoir
passé cette émission est passé ce temps
avec nous merci beaucoup et une bonne un
bon jour du souvenir
merci voilà c'est là dessus que se
termine cette émission spéciale du jour
du souvenir
alors on voit des images donc la place
de la confédération les gens maintenant
qu'ils sont sur place vont pouvoir aller
déposer leurs coquelicot sur la tombe du
soldat inconnu
merci à vous tous de l'avoir suivi avec
nous dans quelques instants c'est le
téléjournal du midi on se laisse donc
sur les images les moments les plus
marquants de ces cérémonies ici et
ailleurs
au revoir
[Musique]